all right uh where are we dropping boys
um the festering woods we're dropping in
vile refuge you have our refugees caught
are you playing fortnight right now
we're dropping an unseen let my dogs
but wait oh no i walked in here i'm
starting to show you
guys oh hang on let me go talk to the
blacksmith first so that i bought the
captain crunch skin
no i just want cereal who is this half
naked person
sort of sort of fondling this sort of
wood basin
that's
are you looking at porno now what's
going on
i'm not sure if i am but i certainly
like what i see
okay
but i'm into it
that's how they get you
um oh here he is corn it's good to see
you well friends it's good to see you
well friend
wow
i think we're almost done here
we are
let me just have to
i have to rage
the mad king of tristram why is he here
are we near tristram
the uh this is the funny part they they
make a reference and one of the
characters says you'd be surprised how
often killing
this guy comes in handy and it's a joke
because in all three diabolos you kill
the skulls
oh really
okay
salvage
fame
salvage all of it
trash the lot of it salvage
the water
turn it into legos all right it's good
to see you well that's all he really
does right is salvage
corn
a lot of vitality going on then
i'm tanking this guy and number good
arrow green
arrow doobie green that's right arrow
good not arrow bad
uh easy i
but do you want to know um that it is on
mobile you can download it right now the
link will be inside i really honestly
think it's all that stuff playing with
bruce
and
steve
apparently having a good time
the game is set between
diablo two and three which is a pretty
exciting era a lot of the real content
going on who is my
character from almost anything ever oh i
got a helmet um and this is where it's
fun to play a video game when i'm
sitting on thousands of blizzard dollars
man oh man that's what people say
they're like is this a sponsored stream
or like first of all it's illegal if i
don't tell you uh second of all i wish
they were paying me hey my stream is
sponsored hey guys
nice
[Laughter]
i'm gonna turn you all down uh bruce can
you tell me more about how you like it
uh so much how are you having a great
time uh could you get more than that
please so you're gonna have to send me
money through my paypal
that would also be illegal i think this
this game we don't want to get into that
with the ftc
steve stop it contracting
i saw you tweeting about how good that
accessibility options are
gonna get those reddit um
but actually steven it is super
accessible
that is oh it's horrible i hate i'm
asking for the good of the people and
not for the good of the good sponsor
okay
the accessibility actually actually is
so really
you know they're actually saying earlier
that what's really cool about this game
is you technically could play this
one-handed um so even our friend no
hands who only has one digit on his hand
could play this game because you really
only have to left-click everything else
pretty optional um you need six inputs
so six keyboard keys are kind of
mandatory yeah um for buttons and mouse
movements but if you can cover that and
uh eye tracking head tracking
um
on screen keyboards also work with this
which is amazing that kind of makes
sense because it's a mobile game as well
right yup and uh the ability to have
auto tracking plus navigation so
essentially you can just kill a monster
click auto navigate it'll take you the
next thing you have to left-click it's
pretty accessible friendly
hell yeah of course there's a great
disabled but yeah
um
yeah that's awesome you love to see it
you love to see it
alan i sent you a squad stream on twitch
show i don't know if you want to let me
go accept that i haven't streamed in so
long i've forgotten how everything works
it's been a while for you haven't hasn't
it uh
like well over a month
yeah
how does anything work
i don't know what's going on
do we want to add her to group bruce and
then gush her up to where we are before
we go further yeah last time i tried to
do it i wasn't allowed so i'll try again
i think that worked
oh you should be allowed to now
uh okay
i will send to carowind
yeah
you just called yourself bruce green
that's your cool fantasy name
okay all right you screen
all right
okay
thanks for the room
thank you so much
that's so not imaginable
can you imagine decade kane saying bruce
green
yeah i can actually thank you well okay
[Laughter]
um
so wait i can come find you now or
you might you might be able to if you
click on one of our portraits you might
be able to teleport oh we we can we have
to go to her because she's the lowest so
okay
you mean most good
then yeah no i don't oh my store's all
in australian dollars
daily remember
there we go okay
i think i'm teleporting to alana
okay
uh you'll know when you see someone
incredibly handsome
whoa wait a minute where are you
where's the
skill thanks so much
uh for reference everybody i am playing
as the wizard
with the friends the fred savage movie
yeah
no the class uh a living conduit of
arcane power
wizards manipulate arcane forces to
strike from a distance disintegrating
their enemies to oblivion
we have a really good wow uh party do we
right now because we have a barbarian i
think that's what steve is oh there you
go
my friend steven bruce green
not that steve all right any better um
you guys didn't want to be koan
well no also
no because i'm getting free advertising
on a lot of stream right now that's true
people can stream
we get additional benefits look at that
wow friendship has pricks where's
lawrence though
i don't know i'm i'm lost in a crowd
right now i teleported to bruce
so if you left click on any of us
lawrence you can click navigate to
player it'll put foot trails where it'll
lead you right to us
all right at least i'm auto running this
time
um i have the phrase navigation paused
on my screen seemingly permanently
yeah so it stays there until you click
on it and lock to a thing so that the
game features you here's how you auto
navigate oh i see
oh oh no did i go too far it's okay you
went into a screen came with you oh
great
look at all my friends navigating with
me
my channel oh yeah my channel is saying
go god alana would make an excellent
audiobook narrator
with my wizard voice
yeah what glossy steve
i'm barbarian the barbarian a savage
wanderer
survivors of the disaster that struck
mount aryat barbarians used brutal
attacks to crush any opposition can you
crush me steve
uh
i mean
crush
me daddy what kind of stuff
[Laughter]
are you
yeah
of course you are
watch this flip oh okay the flip is
pretty cool that was pretty sweet wow
you have like spiderman like tendrils
i mystify your mind i have two uh bow
guns that i shoot in very cool fashions
i do like some overlaying gun gun foo
[ __ ] wow you're really cool
yeah
can you do this
person i mean that's also very cool
steve
can you control the dead
oh
all my friends is cool
a fireball oh hang on i can do a little
gust of wind did you like being ghosted
with everybody
wow that little baby hang on check
is
[Applause]
on a really weird friendship note it's
interesting that all of us pick
different things without any
communication yeah that's actually
awesome
not at all
um okay shall we go questing
yeah we're following we're following you
oh
you're questing with mwah well it's kind
of like wow rules you have to go with
the lowest yeah
i'm just feeling like maybe we shouldn't
help her husband
um is that an option
i mean that seems like are you trying to
cuck somebody or well no because he
would be dead
by the way
[Laughter]
she only has to be crushed once so far
but i struggled
i struggled who shot the bones out of
the ground was that
this position
um okay
you may call him bone dead
somewhere
yeah sorry
oh i got grave light cool so many things
to click on oh my god all right let's go
climb oh i keep getting hilts and gold
yeah it's hot out here being rich
i picked up like 90 gold back there just
because i killed a guy
i hope i can i can buy cool outfits to
make me
yeah he's helping us out
in quotes well they probably noticed
bruce green and steve spawn and they
don't have no idea who care when he is
i'm known across the lands
as a level 11 wizard
[Laughter]
hey
i did see the resident evil 4 trailer i
just uploaded i just re-uploaded my
reaction to the playstation they're like
really cool on my youtube channel
graphic looks really neat
one of you like shooting a hole in
reality yeah like you
yeah
they have hot voices yeah i love all the
voices so far oh i tire of yours
to suppress my
i want one of them to say brother like
they really mean it like a long rolling
r you're not do you think that i need to
main sponsored okay
[Laughter]
we didn't talk about balls earlier don't
worry about it
you should
important stuff it was uh testicular
cancer awareness month in april
yeah give him a rub down
he's gonna give him a give him a rub
down
you're supposed to massage him in the
shower and like roll them around in a
triad of fingers you can
look up the exact details it's how
you're supposed to do it
check for it just try and do it once a
month you know i've been doing it three
years
did somebody else do it for you steve or
uh yeah nice yeah actually bruce was
actually offering earlier for over half
a million dollars you were willing to go
with a wheelchair into the bathroom is
that great i hear that right
hang on a minute should i should i have
accepted this quest that somebody just
started
uh that's fine so chad is their audio
okay now killing angry pete
also chet yes this is the guy who hosted
the accessibility awards with me i don't
know about thinking he's awesome
slow it down
[Music]
just said to me certainly didn't expect
to get choked by some death mage okay
it's asking for it what do you want me
to say i am
jesus
killing for the information
and you just gave me over here right
i think i maybe did something i think
all my friends maybe left me um we're
killing angry people we're dealing with
them
sorry
okay we're therapying right now
oh i'm leaving the event area
come back come back you get the rewards
okay i'm coming back we were impatient
okay there's a big chest over here i
completed the event
it's okay
apparently i completed the event wow you
guys left all these health clubs here
for me
i actually like the health globes i
don't know exactly how it works yet so
q
has
four quadrants are those are the
quadrants refreshed by the health globes
oh yeah i suppose so are they i don't
actually know
where they are so q has four i think
it's oh no it might be third sorry it
might just be thrust
like you pick up a piece so they don't
refill your phones
gotcha automatically refill on a timer
oh really oh no okay okay
yeah usually in the regular games you
have to buy potions
the leather tunic
oh that's rare that's big time
you're gonna want to pick that up i did
thank you is that red that's right
you're telling me that's that led the
tunic is red
yeah that's 30 40 bucks
probably mm-hmm
yeah you have to send oh what are these
oh
consulting fees oh
leeches oh they had gold on them
what are you doing with money
come on
my favorite is always the like gold
freak
like they were on their way to the pose
or something
you put a stop to that
well the one thing i'm loving about
these like area events and really quest
thing in general yeah sorry what other
events because i missed it when you did
it what what exactly was it so like
they're just random timed events that
pop up and they say would you like to
join and if one of us clicks join we all
do it like this
cool
there's a bad guy
phil the bad guy seeing a few actually
hang on let me pull out my full beam
before you roll
oh that is a cool game thank
level 20 baby
well you know some say that level 12 is
the new level 20.
no one said that hey my chat said it
quick type it and i'll tell
but hang on i have a two second delay on
chat so
um
okay well we'll we'll figure in the
delay oh it's in there
yeah no it's uh seemingly sober they
said it pull that up
here
[Laughter]
really slow you're doing it really hard
you sound like my dad if my dad knew
what twitch was
where is that chest
do you tell me it's our secret oh no i
lost i'm not seeing any chests no way oh
there's an absolute lack of maidens out
here it was over here
thanks steve you're really bad at being
a bad guy
hey
yes what does real mean
yeah i can tell you're totally hurt
anyway
that's not even like the top 10 10
meanest things i've read about myself
today so you're all right
man seeing lawrence flipping the action
like that i know the flips are actually
sick what class you learn
i'm a demon hunter the demon hunter a
vengeful stalker relentless vigilantes
that assault from afar demon hunters
strike undeterred until their prey is at
their mercy
that's what you wanted right you wanted
you wanted me to do that
she memorized it
yeah i know that
it's actually playing a sponsored stream
she had to learn all the classes
i've never felt cooler thank you that
felt cooler than when i'm doing sweet
flips and that feels really cool so
big deal
okay nice can you do some flips can i
watch you flip again i just dude that's
really cool
yes you can
damn i need to put on my uh my like
equilibrium dance
one i'm gonna be honest i wish you were
the female character though just so i
can pretend that we're killing things
with underworld that'd be great
[Music]
that would be cool maybe you can change
it around
damn
you really are morbid out here man
how is it that like
treating my studies
like guns
dome if it's a movie as evidenced by
hansel and grenell witch hunters and or
whatever it was and uh
van helsing don't you talk any smack
about
han belsing
hand bell singing i love that movie uh
because i loved it as a kid for some
reason which should tell you of his
quality it was like one of my favorite
movies as a kid wait is it the one with
the hugh jackman yeah yeah oh man that
one's terrible i love it yeah it's
it's really something that's real bad
but anyway but like the auto bow gun
isn't as cool as it should be in that
movie right
i don't remember
yeah i don't remember
when he's fighting the like energy club
that's cool
and they're like harassing the town he
whips up this like auto bow gun oh
wonder i feel like i'm talking to
yourself here
well when i don't i don't remember the
last time i saw that movie if i'm being
perfectly honest yeah yeah sorry we're
totally listening
we should watch that you guys want to
have a movie night anyone want to come
over and watch
this
will you watch a real movie
i have oh have i got a pitch for you
guys yes i've had for a while okay go on
yeah i have to get a 4k rip of mortal
kombat annihilation okay then
i put it through adobe premiere and i
bump up its video its frame rate to 120
fps okay and then i use like ai
interpolation to make it the smoothest
video experience
i think it's the best idea i've ever had
and and you put on motion smoothing on
your tv oh yeah oh yeah
i got i got attack speed upgrade and
lightning boost just in this little area
we got to go to the next
[Music]
oh you guys are really strong wow
cool friends i have
boom oh there's nobody there you killed
them before my spell was able to be cast
you bet we did
i'm not mad about it
who's making noise
who just want more oh resurrect player
should i resurrect wow
what what is it
they have to accept it they have to
accept it
give him a shot
that's what he wants yeah
where's the hidden layer it's still
hidden
where's the hidden layer
challenge also the way you guys say let
is very silly
yeah
how r is pronounced
ah let's enter the dungeon layer
that feels better
characters right now where is that layer
i don't know where that layer is
you know what where is that dawnless
it's a hidden layer bruce it's got to
have some good stuff hidden layer
real good it's a hidden layer yeah it
did say hidden pretty specifically
adventurer proceed to the hidden layer
don't you don't think the ropes i don't
know where i'm going i'm just running
around i'm trying to find this layer
listen i'm following you like you know
what you're doing
this is my first time i do have two
streaming slash recording a video
maybe second time with the the dog in
the room
and i'm pleased to report that he's
being a perfect danger
oh that's great he's just sleeping
where's that later sorry no where's that
layer
where's my lair
tell you what if my guy had
[Music]
who cares i didn't mean to distract from
dog talk i was i was into it guys who
cares
when he was first in the house
would chew anything when left alone just
chew anything and everything go he'd go
ham on all of it and it's slowly like
become a good dog
and i think i can let him kind of roam
around freely now without having to
worry about him destroying my couch
that's great i think so yeah
that's really good muscle executed
that said he started to be allowed to go
for walks
um
he wasn't allowed for a long time
because he was having uh rehab
after surgery um because he's an
alcoholic yes
no he had a full hip replacement
and it
wiped him out like he goes for a 10
minute walk and then has to sleep for
six hours
that's so nice yeah he's getting it back
he's making it happen he pees on himself
every time he tries to mock territory
because he still can't quite use his
legs
[Music]
well i think i'm waiting for alana
because a lot of us to
let me continue
i thought we were looking for that that
layer
i don't worry about the layer who cares
about layers i'm talking to darlene
magical identification do you require
magical yeah it's not
it's not kane what is that [ __ ]
i do like kane okay well i came to the
place it told me to hang out can we not
talk to him again what is my quest
oh what does a rank transfer
thank you maybe that's what i'll do for
you i think i get it
yes you upgrade something and then you
can transfer it to another item
he knows i can see him that's what it
seems like to me
weapons take time to
oh my god paulie almost sounds like matt
berry
he just went i'm working as fast as i
can
and that's fairly fast all right
it's very close and it's incredible the
stress is eating everyone alive that
here i've gone half the lot done just
take oh
well well i've upgraded two things and i
cannot transfer either one okay you
might yeah
and with half these another item of the
same like
a shoulder pad or a pant or something
more and more these undead right
and my men are tired
still
all right carowind where to make do i'm
talking to captain asmir i'm certain you
didn't come all this way to deliver me
abundance um what brings you to god's
watch i'm looking for queen of sellers
for my handmaid
it's all right ayan [ __ ] yeah okay
ooh
i unlocked equipment upgrades look at me
go all right this way lots
[Music]
did you get a new equipment upgrade i
unlocked the ability to upgrade
equipment i don't think i got a new
equipment upgrade one step at a time if
you do that you'll get rewards
i love those oh gee
if you give us just ten dollars we'll
give you a reward
okay
do you mean like spending money for your
miner everybody the stream is exactly
what that is
game stream right now check it out yeah
do you think i'm gonna find a maiden in
here
there is a lot of blood in here yeah
oh how did you guys get through here oh
you punched it
yeah that's cool too late we're good too
later
don't worry about it everybody i pooped
lightning
i just saw someone in general chat fall
for the beaufort of course
my old students had to work
the body's still warm too a dude named
sigma you may not
watch out folks that's right morm's
[ __ ] yours
tuck your pants into your socks
everybody we got a we got a meme hound
on the loose yeah he's been saving up
for this uh iced tea this game is on
mobile but it's also on pc evidently
he's writing down his notes he's ready
for diablo immortal to watch
would it be good today my voice to the
soul of the recent
gosh
this is pretty intense you guys know
what yeah wow anymore clicking through
all the dialogue
there's a pretty quality like lady
scream
yeah
oh yeah
yeah i was like damn see the real vocals
in this game go for it i like how it was
[Music]
i don't know where it is though does
anybody know
they don't
where's the lane somebody find it
someone said i can imagine this being
good on switch me too i don't think it's
on switch but it doesn't feel like it's
going to stay here
my studies have paid off money which is
your bodies have paid off it seems oh
you guys are unlocked teleport
nobody does that
i'm looking for this
there's a ton of skulls up here there's
like some blueberries
cool
i can teleport there's some elites up
here
guys you guys figure out where the layer
is i need you to see how cool they found
some elites
we're doing it again does this have
control of support
yes he's leaving behind hey i'm well oh
guys there's a grave defiling he seems
angry
okay
and much stronger than me and he's
frozen me
oh no oh no
all we had to do was wait in the room
and we couldn't do it
we couldn't do it
immune to knock back what is this some
kind of god
oh gosh oh gosh
i think he put my potions on cooldown
somehow
oh look look who rolled in the day like
the cool guy he
alana is like
help and then steve stopped to kill the
mobs along the way
i knew it i knew it
yeah i did it all by myself cool chest
cold chest bruce
did you guys find the hidden layer
no no no
no our friend was like i can't beat this
video game we had to run who who said
that i didn't hear anybody say that
that's
that's so weird
oh yeah that turns out yeah
that makes sense
i'm entering a team find that layer
well
let's accept oh
no this is just a story
i don't know i would say this is pretty
hidden by my definition
uh
everybody goes into here that's not
got to stop sharing your location bud
it's too easy
storyline of every marvel movie you'll
never find my hidden layer located on
the island underneath the volcano
that's also a way to find legendary
pokemon
you're right it's true what's that chest
nothing came out of it
i got stuff oh you guys were already
done
oh you're so cool mobs
i saw that and it was cool
right like i didn't even care i do
though a lot
thanks
care deeply hey check this out steve
look
yeah yep you see it do you see what i
did
what no
it's fine don't worry about it
[Music]
wow oh wait yeah this teleport yeah i
teleported yeah yeah check out this
telly hang on hang on teleporting ready
they definitely nest a little bit
you were over there and then you're over
there it's true that's exactly how what
happened yeah
you guys i'm level 15 now
well it looks like the they don't [ __ ]
the health but they do buff the damage
because even at level 20.
[Applause]
how's the healing going i'm doing pretty
well luigi my face is still a little bit
swollen
uh what is his name martin
charles
charles martin
timothy
i
still have bruises oh i'm sorry chris
pratt you're right that's chris pratt
but uh and it still hurts and i can't
wash my hair yet it's been a week and i
haven't been able to wash my hair but
i'm doing good
does mario level up in mario
no that's well i guess there's mario rpg
i'm trying to think of like i guess it
was scott pilgrim video game or
cinematic moments where characters
literally level up
oh i'm just running sorry
i want to mention the cool thing that
just happened just because i think it's
neat so is that me telling
you're awesome but besides that we i got
through uh the dungeon and uh the
exclamation mark showed up on my screen
i clicked it and it said you just
completed a content of morphs would you
like to add them as a friend
and then i clicked yes he clicked accept
a dialogue between our characters going
you shouldn't go alone let's go together
you've spoke to each other
let's see hello
the source of profane right
right it's first
that's me no or he's either very
eloquent
or he's um
bobby hill
resource of propane rat here i don't
know how to how to do a bobby hill uh pr
how does he sound like
um
no i can't do it it's impossible can't
be done uh or race after remembering an
impossible impossible impression
nobody's ever done it oh why does my
face say exp
i don't know
full of reflections
destroy death ritual
what kind of music are you kids
listening to over here
[Music]
[Music]
bruce why are you so shiny
because i'm great
oh
okay why because i'm awesome
thank you
awesome
all right that's not the way a
necromancer would talk probably sound
more like bobby hill actually that's
true
that's where i should have teleported
away
okay eddie redmayne
i think that all you do is imagine
jupiter i really do bring it up a lot
don't i talk about it a lot like the
number one thing you imagine i think
maybe is stupid ascending
and i don't mind it you got me on board
pretty hard
i've got all this shocking stretch
recently without thinking about it but
yeah i kind of broke my streak
you no i mean that like
when i watched it with the contacts that
you gave me i was all right with the
film it was not you know it's when it's
a trilogy that's the problem it's a
trilogy in one movie
and also it's twilight
json animates
lauren lawrence is the only person i
know who talks about that movie it's the
same with me j shawn i only
he's the only person any of us know that
talks about cheaper attending
it's a silly thing to hit your brand too
i i gotta mix it up here
i gotta make some plays
i uh oh on that note i think i found
another movie that it doesn't bring up
okay
uh i i've been diving into the y2k
rom-coms late
um there's a lot of bad stuff out there
hopefully
i found this uh i found this like
teen spy thriller called debs
okay here's the premise
uh when you take the sat
sure it's for college or whatever but
actually it's a secret spy test to see
if you'd be a good spot so
yeah our our lead
took the
18
the sat test
scored so high
and then joined the debs program which i
guess is like a surrogate house like
four-year program you can see a cool
spot
here and stuff
and uh and then when you graduate
depending on how good of a deb you were
they don't ever say what the acronym
stands for in the movie either you have
to look that up what is it
ah damn it's like
damn
dynamism energy
uh beauty
and why would beauty be on that that's
messed up
yeah well maybe because you're a spine
you have to be beautiful well it's you
know it's why 2k attitudes were
different but here's the twist
the uh our our lead
um
thank you cody
sent a spy on jordana brewster
who is a
international terrorist who goes by the
name lucy diamond i think because she's
a diamond theater
uh and the first time she looks at her i
will our lead looks at jordana burster
through binoculars bam she's a legend
just like immediately it explodes within
her and the rest of the movie is
basically her having
you're falling in love with jordana
brewster while she's also a spot
hell yeah
pretty it's a pretty sick movie all
right i'm down
is that the end of it uh well i mean
there's a lot more than that i mean come
on
but deb's content is it's just the well
goes on
yeah bottom has an extended unit the
devs excuse me
they have their own things going on
she's got an ex
he has to work out his feelings there
too
you can imagine bruce her ex is feeling
pretty twisted up about
about uh her being in love with lucy
diamond you can no more put me down this
time
also she's a terrorist so that throws a
wrench and goes oh i think her brother
also works for the dod
over the undead you just found a new
quest while i was just told to kill the
oreck
fine over here it's over here to rest
oh look at he moved away so fast
i don't know what these things are
scrap materials
i feel like i maybe don't need to do any
of this
get more what time frame do you consider
y2k era hmm
i'm not sure when did avatar come out i
think avatar shut the book seven 2008
yeah that's late but i'm going to say
that another nine no nine
probably more like nine i don't know
what's going on okay yeah that's a
little too late
when did white dude that's real money uh
it's actually when the world stopped in
2000. yeah when all the computers
exploited yeah
i'm in a rank purchase menu right now to
rank two rewards is this battle pass
stuff only
no that's the free battle pass so as
long as you don't click rank up you'll
be okay all right we got it deb stands
for discipline energy beauty strength
oh because they're women
yeah they're young and hot oh they're
all wearing like hideous white 2k
fashions like babydoll tees and mini
skirts and crunchy hairdos and no it's
because i hit rank up that's the problem
okay
we're doing a thing i'm finally killing
incredible in retrospect but if the
ladies were enjoying it and they liked
the way they looked then that's all that
matters you said the same thing about me
the reason that i now get my eyebrows
tattooed is because i plucked the pants
off of them
in the early 2000s and they never grew
back uh so i have beef with that era
the creams stuff does microblading too
it's good
[Music]
they take over people's bodies
that would have been great
oh oh i got another okay so this is the
more modern
uh it costs money too to be aware of
that but it's called uh we need to talk
right
and it's about a streamer
right and now you know why i'm
interested okay because i love i love
movies about my culture it's about a
streamer
who's like a 30-something or whatever
but he just can't grow up you know he's
just he's just freezing through life
and why would he need to
yeah right he's got it all
uh so he's he's waking up one morning
uh and then his girlfriend says hey we
need to talk
and he's like whatever babe i'm i'm too
busy thinking about video games for work
in on it you're not answering my
question
what
how wild
how wild that is what he lost yeah
wild uh
very loud
all right pretty wild
i mean it's it's mostly on the internet
um and through through you watch videos
so moderately um dark souls this does
feel
a lot like the app it's not like diablo
3
copy but like it it really is
diablo-like because it's very much
in a way that i respect
uh i keep trying to use the waz keys to
to walk
oh i didn't know you could you can't
wait
it's a mobile game so i i can but it i
only have a walk in one direction
i can't navigate with them yeah
it is it is working as as normal for me
what are my direction keys no
yeah if i press
uh no yeah
i mean it could could just be a bug it
doesn't just open beta on pc
guys i'm stuck i'm stuck between morbs
i can't leave this place
yeah lawrence or either that or mouse
over like it's weird it's like the
bottom right of the gate
ah there it is yep thank you it's really
hard to find
that's a cunning mystery never heard
that before either
[Music]
we need like a bell or something we can
ring whenever stephen stephen
yeah
i mean well i mean we were having a
conversation about streamers and you
know i wanted to be able to relate oh
look at this creepy guy under the ground
look at him
i know it's really cool actually hanging
on the glass
he just wants to get out he's not trying
to beef he's just like
oh my god people are here finally
they still make peanut butter pretzels
i love trader joes
they forgot my sauce
doordass jokes they get me every time i
i'm never jealous of anything
from my friends too
but alana's ability to do voices for
things like doordash makes me cuz you
could just call there when you're mad
and just do the best robotic angry voice
ever how do you call goldash can you
even oh yeah i guess they would have a
customer service
yeah whenever they've plucked up your
order you could just be like how do you
ever need me to get angry at somebody
for you
ah
you you let me know
alana will you be the one to say that
that shouldn't have pickles on it
yes
and whatever accent you asked for steve
i got you
are you are you sure you really want to
offer to get mad yeah it's a good point
that's a good point that's a full-time
job like that happens to me a lot yeah i
take it back looks like a full-time job
so it's true
oh push back a little push back huh a
little push back cutie
all right
don't fear me
oh look at these skulls
oh
they do 436 damage oh
nice spin steve nice spin
i'm kind of hoping that this game goes
nuts on that stuff
make it near just do it
all right
to the throne room to the throne room i
think i'm stuck on the rocks hang on
a track is king queen of desire
oh my gosh gargoyles
gargles
argyles
gargles and stylix
i will i will mention one word on the
subject controls i did have a hilarious
troll this week who literally
when i was again talking about being
inclusive how dare me uh
literally tweeted and said oh my god
it's you again i'm not up about
inclusivity
it's just like comically evil
to be against including people is
just so
villainous
yeah how dare you talk about including
people a thing that is objectively like
kind
well
well it's not unpacked that too far but
mostly
very kind
so wild
they they have like forced inclusivity
they have to be it has to be a troll
right they have to be they have to be
fixed
yeah most of us will show you the tweet
it's hilarious i just i want to frame it
you want me to prison tattoo it on your
back
i thought oh you're gonna offer this to
do it on your back which one am i right
okay
i had a really good troll the other day
a friend posted themselves playing uh
xbox series x um
with the the kickstarted like attachable
screen thing i forget what it's called i
got one actually i haven't tried it yet
but basically it's a tiny little screen
that you attach directly to your xbox
series s
and someone was like how's performance
or whatever and i replied and i was like
yeah you see the reason it's called xbox
series s is because ss was small because
the resolution is only really small so
it only works on small screens and
someone was like um no that's ridiculous
and i was like no you're wrong
[Laughter]
i misspelled everything
and
this guy was like wow
this is like you're really stupid and i
was like no you are and
and then like
yeah and he doubled down and
was like eventually someone was like
look her up you know she's joking and he
was like it doesn't matter i was
trolling anyway it's like no no you
weren't you won you super one
i was being stupid
it was really funny
checkmate
it was a very good text message uh sorry
i twitter conversation i was cracking up
laughing it at very politely trolling
somebody by pretending that the xbox
series s only works on little tiny
screens
you know that dude's going to be fuming
about that
i just thought of the perfect reply but
it's not stupid if i do it now
no but it's the fact that he was like i
was just trolling where are you
where are you
yeah i said the s means is small
genius isn't microsoft i've done it
again
although a series does look like an
attached screen that's very beautiful
it's really cool it was part of a
kickstarter i've been meaning to unbox
it and actually try it out i haven't
done it yet yeah super super cool um so
you can it basically makes it like a
laptop portable
yeah i've seen it it's really cool yeah
it's really neat
like i i take the s with me pretty
frequently when i travel
because it's so you only took the l gosh
man
how does he do it sorry sorry that
wasn't very inclusive steve
i inflated you in the church
only me what about bruce and lawrence
they take l2 well they didn't offer them
was that was a negative advantage
okay
well look at him he's got a whole ass
horse
of course
one whole ass
it big that's one ass power
when you officially reach like the rich
enough to buy your friends horses level
can i have a horse i'd like a horse too
oh i want to vote absolutely not no you
don't want to vote boats require so much
money this is for fake friends
think of what would autumn say autumn
love horse
nope she doesn't get one only my fake
friends that have been with me for like
two months that's it only fake friends
that's drake's new song
oh hello
all right you have to love me for my
money and then and then
and then you get a horse okay
that's literally the whole point i'm
after this horse
yeah i think
well okay which do you think costs more
like a monthly maintenance to own a
horse on a boat
you were gonna say his love or vote no
it's boat well a boat you just have to
pay for the slip but a horse you got to
do all sorts of things do you know how
much fuel is no yeah fuel and then also
like you have to no
you just climb onto it and let it float
in the harbor and then you play your
xbox series s on it
that's a great call
yeah he's got you look at all the
the doc birds walking around with that
one
i got a new spell and i don't know where
to put it
it's got a really long cooldown
but it looks really cool
man you know who also has a really long
cooldown
you know what i'm saying
oh
i see very good
very nice
my refractory period takes forever
that's what i'm saying
and that's a negative okay
that's true uh ghostwriter you can pass
that's fine
it's just self-centered that's all
negative is strong chat would you like
to see the dog would you like to see him
would you like to see him are you
stealing our views with the dogs sleepy
baby you like to where's that dog there
he is you're not supposed to help her
there he is luckily i have the auto
complete up because i had to verify the
chat from earlier so this is sleepy me
where's that dog
he's sleeping
he's sleeping
what a good dog you see his little
carrot toy
can you like can you give him a little
poke hang on hang on if i slap my leg
no
there he is
good morning
oh big stretch oh
but he gets to go right back to sleep
it's the best feeling in the world when
you get to just roll over and be like
he's such a good guy i wake up i always
wake up my dog whenever she's sleeping
in the middle of the day because i'm
like this is [ __ ] you're not doing
anything and then i wake up
that's abusive oh are we going to mad
king's breach
did we want to go here yeah yeah oh okay
cool
um i had this thing oh he's
i used to try to wake him up during the
day because when we first got him
he would wake up at about 5 a.m and cry
to go to the bathroom so then when he
started to go to bed at eight i was like
wake up [ __ ]
no go to sleep yet you gotta stay home
but he's fine now exactly that's the
problem
it just kind of went away
oh it's time to talk to zul
got away oh she got away she was right i
couldn't do it oh my god i couldn't kill
so many notifications to click i just
claimed a bunch of rewards
sometimes you'll click one thing and
it'll unlock another thing
the stream is sponsored
by diablo
all right
oh i just noticed that there's little
numbers over our heads uh it's available
now check it out click the link
download free to play mobile pc
obviously playing with four friends it
was really easy to find each other
good stuff
uh okay i don't know where all my homies
went but that's fine i guess
we're killing shahzad killing shazam
hey chazot
[Music]
glorious chest ahead i really appreciate
you guys inviting me to come get chess
with you tonight
oh
somebody got some maidens
okay i have to do something solo
temporarily apparently oh that's fine
yeah whatever
it's cool that it actually just this you
will never have are you at the point
where you have to talk to
i'm we're we're on that close to
leftists we have to go
yeah we have to do that too oh so i
should back out
have you fought left this
no
okay
i think i gotta do it i think i think i
don't have maybe don't have choice i
think maybe i initiated it now i have
she's got like like doom uh skulls
like pain elemental doom skulls ah so
many of them
just like a pain elemental from the hit
game doom
i decided recently that i've been lying
to everybody and that deadly premonition
is not my favorite
it's not true
it's doom 1993
solid pig and i love it i just love it
so much
well no i just changed my mind wow
oh no oh no oh i wish my friends were
here to help
except for bursting we're on the way you
call me alive
oh i'm just kidding it's a solo story
yeah i think it is solo yeah
so we all have to do it solo yep
interesting oh yeah you might as well i
already did it
my teleport was paying off in spades hey
lads
i'd be looking i'm real cool
if you guys died doing that um uh i
would just get a horse we get a horse
if we die doing it
i would just do that
because you're bad at this
it sounds like maybe you speak from
experience because maybe you died when
you did it no no no no
no no no
okay
that's how it sounds
forever
i'ma ask the vaude that's what i'm
asking
on stat vod
i do think this game is pretty
challenging it's actually hotter than i
expected
yeah i'm pretty down with the bullet
waves they're doing i hope that's the
thing
i hope they continue
so close
very close very close oh and i got it
i wish that this this
troll
i don't know what's to describe it
would just leave me alone
the bone golem it's a golem
of course it's a golem
that's why i call myself sometimes you
know on a friday night you know what i'm
saying i'm a golem
[Music]
yeah it was yeah
thanks for noticing appreciate it
oh she just keeps summoning them
in a bone golem
oh man i'll stomach my balls
what about lawrence um
yeah what i didn't even see a bone golem
what are you doing right now more down
through i uh i am going to talk to
lieutenant dylan i am in westwood
okay
that's where we're going right that's
not what i'm doing well most of us are
already not one of the closest immune to
control
nobody is
don't [ __ ] yourself up let me know let
me know
yeah i'm probably going to die i'm
probably going to die
no
um try not to find kane talk to fury on
the bridge
oh i'm talking to period right now
you are oh [ __ ] okay i can go do that
i died
revive that corpse revive at checkpoint
probably
revive the corpse okay happens to the
best of us hey wait charlie apparently
that's a name from diablo
oh i'm still here oh oh i'm still
fighting her can i leave
you have to keep killing you got to kill
you must keep killing skill
she has so much health i was trying to
have a drink of water trying to hydrate
and the game said no
we got a little bone shield
i know
nice because i'm a necromancer yeah you
like bones emo yeah emo bastard
i don't think they are i don't think
bones are emo
oh no i don't think so i don't think emo
kids
like bones water bone
goth maybe yeah yeah i got oh
okay yeah i accept that
all right
i am in the safe zone
still just fighting with this hot chick
health returns
oh it's charcy
oh
i didn't know a lady in high school that
collected bones i think that's cool
yeah she was pretty cool what kind of
horses and then she would be like hey
there's a skull and then she'd get off
the horse stick the skull in her back
and take it off it's cool that's cool
yeah i mean it's definitely weird
that's weird
high school you collected bones
she just wanted more bones
more little baby bones
i can make my own bone get away from me
golem
leave me alone
oh health webs oh health clubs yes yes
health bugs yes yes yes yes oh my god
she has so much help
what do you think those things are
filled with like red jello
just gotta swallow it all down
and i haven't had jello in like 20 years
jello is just jelly right why don't you
guys call it jelly is that because you
call jelly jam not jelly it's not brand
it's a gelatin
it's like you know it's like kleenex do
you have airplane jelly
you mean jello i love aeroplane jelly
airplane jelly for me
not familiar what the hell are you doing
oh this is one of my story that is
australianism my friends
hey have you guys heard of the nut bush
by any chance
come on whoa
do you know nut bush
so this is like a big topic of
conversation on the latest episode of
idiots and abroad it'll be out next
monday um
that night bush by tina turner a song
song that exists a real song
uh i guess americans just don't know
whereas it may as well be a national
anthem in australia
we have a dance that we do to the nut
bush
yeah yeah and americans are like i don't
even know that tina turner's song i
ain't heard that dang song in my name
that's what all the americans say
whereas in australia we go nuts
oh not bush it's one of the few songs or
the first song that she wrote completely
by herself uh independently of ike
[Music]
yeah we really don't like them over
there
it's good taste okay
ah oh uh okay you can summon me i can't
teleport the world stone emanates from
the dark wood
so i just i just did the thing where i
transferred an item and it's automatic
when you equip it it just says you want
to
transfer all the upgrades you've made to
this item slot
i probably had loads of leveling that i
could have been doing
oh gosh oh gosh
oh so you're basically just upgrading
the item slide not the item
yeah
unless there's a hidden cost i didn't
see it take oh
ah
as an unincorporated rural community nut
bush does not have official city limits
wow
can spread anywhere really so she's
talking about not butch city limits even
though technically it does not exist
the limit does not exist that's the joke
i think that's the deal do you think
that tina turner was playing silly
buggers on us
i like that usually we're going to let
that go by and i was like again i don't
know what's australian and what's not
i was just saying
i think people use it on children a lot
who say it about children a lot that's a
good children phrase use it on children
say
hello
why can't i use anything right now
hi
uh-huh
conversation here
rearranged nut heals
uh i am not i wasn't able to be summoned
because of this boss fight with this hot
chick
yeah you gotta beat her very persistent
i'm getting there i just talked to
decker team for much oh
gonna get the elder rift and then i
think we can all do this together okay
uh question uh
because i'm an incredibly mature and
emotionally not stunted man uh can we
make our kill that we have to make
together because we're friends obviously
nut bush like that
thank you i feel represented and so does
tina turn up oh long may she live
morphs votes gay for nut bush
isn't she dead or is she no she's not
dead
oh she's great she's still out here
morbin
all right good i want to make sure some
more everybody's more of an outfit yeah
she's moving away i'm pretty sure she's
not dead
no no otherwise australia will be truly
devastated australia and not bush
tennessee
oh my god she's so close to dying and
i'm so low on health
please just die
not tina turner no we love tina turner
[Music]
[Applause]
i just want you to die so bad
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on no don't die k owen not
now
i did it
well done it's done
you have done it
hell yeah
all right gamers we gaming out here
everybody click the link in the
description if you want to check out the
game i really enjoyed it